okay lay down go ahead and lay down in
corpse pose use the whole matter so your
feet are about six inches apart let them
fall outward turn your palms up your
arms are 45 degree angle downward from
your spine get them in the diagonal
[Music]
gently roll your shoulder blades under
and relax your feet so they point
outward naturally close your eyes
release your jaw and I want you to
observe right now where you are in
relation to the max
what does it feel like a sign that a
value right now I am at X X pressure on
the mat what I want you to do is the
head-to-toe conscious relaxation release
each muscle group starting at the crown
of your head go down your face release
the tongue shoulders throat and the jaw
the jaw release the jaw more MORE
the upper chest the abdomen and so on
and start to see if that x-value starts
to increase in pressure as you're
releasing that muscle tension do you
feel you feel yourself through that
releasing increasing your pressure into
the mat feeling yourself sinking into
the mat more and keep releasing so you
keep increasing that pressure onto the
mat it's a two-fold releasing your
thoughts are releasing and those
thoughts are releasing your muscle
tension
feel that pressure on the map increase
as you become heavier as you begin to
sink more into the mat by releasing not
holding yourself up above the mat once
you hit your feet come back up your body
combining thought and relaxation to
release yourself more increasing more
pressure more sinking into the map more
releasing
now you're going to do conscious tension
tense your muscles squeeze your fists
resist with your thoughts and decrease
the pressure onto the mat and now
release and increase that pressure
through releasing
release more standing the body head to
toe toe to head feeling the pressure
increase as you sink more into the mat
I'm going to be in just--she's anytime
my feet are under my hips
and whatever state I'm in I'm gonna
start relaxing and see if I can get that
increased value at my feet just by
releasing and relax
see if I could also feel my hands pull
down on me maybe the blood you'll feel
immediately rush of blood into the
fingertips and release and the same
thing start from the head lys throat the
shoulders we might not be aware so you
want to consciously pass through the
pelvis pass through the gluts a lot of
times you're holding an unconscious
tension in the gluts release the legs
and then there tends to be an
unconscious tension in the lower legs as
well release that and see if you can
feel even just the slightest increase in
pressure with the knife okay go ahead
and try okay so here's what tends to
happen so one you'll have a unconscious
flexion in the lower
but once you release you'll feel this
fall and it'll scare you and you will
tense up again so you tend to feel this
one at first in little pulses you
understand so I want you to come out of
it and actually feel for the little
pulses there and then I'll come out okay
so is there not a gravitational pull of
myself downward yes creates a vector
what I'm doing when I release is tilt is
to allow all of that vector to happen in
a purely vertical manner that's gonna be
the heaviest I can be do you do you
understand if I'm leaning like this my
feet are not the heaviest but if I put
my mouse over my feet that's the
heaviest
okay
first drill relaxing allows me to sing
releasing allows me to sync tension for
some reason holds me up go vertical now
practice is same releasing and see if
we're sensitive enough to feel the
weight drop with an increased pressure
at my feet next row I'm out of it
so we maintain sensitivity go back in
and feel it out feel it release feel it
out okay this next drill I'm going to
specify the vector maybe for example
when you were releasing you felt this do
you see that that the vector is towards
my heels it's back here when I release
because of my knee angle my pelvis angle
maybe my head angle let's go it's behind
my midpoint of my foot and I fall under
fall backwards okay it's quite common
today because you have tight rear cross
their chains so we're going to specify
the vector we call it mid foot you know
where the ball of your foot is right
you're going to take about an inch with
the top of that inches at the bottom of
the ball of the foot
let me see that and then you change the
vector that goes down the middle of your
foot and I'm about here you see that
right where crucifixion nails go okay
now that I release I'm going to play
with my hip pelvis angle me pen head
angle to make sure that release is
pushing into that spot and you combine
the sensitivity this is energy the mass
of my body and gravity is in energy and
I'm now aiming it through releasing and
letting it fall on that my mouth release
let it fall on that you won't
necessarily feel the outside of your
edges press down you mind it more feels
like that little spot opens the weight
comes here and the outer circumference
of that dog gets pushed out
okay I'm here consciously release just
like drill one and aim it down onto that
mid foot then come out so I regain
sensitivity try now we're going to play
with the aiming of the vector more I'm
gonna purposely lose it or better yet
challenge myself to keep it there right
here everything was static okay first
Amy is through deep breathing so get in
position put your vector on that spot
and I'll demonstrate then you will be a
half feet behind me you'll see what I
mean I'm going to inhale deeply if I
don't do anything I push the way
backwards right don't move your head try
it again
stop listen to my directions don't move
anything get the vector in place don't
move your eyes and now take a deep
breath don't move anything full deep
breath if you're not falling backwards
you have conscious unconscious tension
that's keeping you locked in place okay
and each drill we go on that's why you
need to do the drill so if you could not
feel the release here it's because you
don't have sensitivity to the tension
and so we need to first get that if in
this drill you don't feel your weight go
backwards with that big breath again you
don't have sensitivity and you're doing
is micro flex
I'll hold it in place so watch I'm gonna
take a big breath I'm gonna flex you
won't see any change in my pelvis hey
you see but if I release blue to
release can we do that without
consciously faking it okay
go Kate I'm going to keep everything
relaxed I'm not going to hold myself in
place with the tension let's go back to
drill one what allows for the increased
value of x relaxation okay so don't get
lured by the increased value the
increased value is just a marker for the
relaxation the relaxation is what we
want okay I can't relax for all the dark
reasons fear anxiety pride ignorance
ignorance in this case I'm not sensitive
enough that it's beyond my awareness
okay but now I'm going to do something
that would take me back but I'm going to
play with my head my pelvis angle my
knee angle and my ankle angle okay
that'll keep the vector but I don't
tense up because I know if I tensed up I
didn't eat any of that do you understand
so you're gonna watch I first do the
other drill everything
please take a big inhale and you'll see
different things will start to move you
can see this
[Music]
and that exhale I'll have to change it
the chin is going out
and the whole time I'm doing this my
mind is consciously releasing and
observing for tension release the glutes
the chin is coming up and I well what do
you move I just used the vector as my
aim do you understand and your body will
intuitively know turn this term that but
then you have to consciously release
attention that does not need to be there
okay try it
it'll require more manipulation of those
articulation points so establish the
point feel this spray my head I moved my
head drop it and you're going to see my
knees are dropping just to keep that
vector but keep consciously relaxing you
can see my publicist starting to come up
and picks it up
I'm going to leave my angles where they
are the hips tell this nice watch what's
going to happen can you see it I'm going
forward so I can't even wear their
release have the established vector pick
up start to change it my knees are going
back release the gluts they're not
important
keep the vector aimed at the designated
location release release release release
release release release now I'm going to
stop articulation if I keep moving my
head what's gonna happen she's going
back so it has to change legs are
extending slightly
this
okay again the contracts I know my
objective keep weight falling on the
mid-foot designated point to relax and
release the muscle tension so that the
vector is flowing down three I don't I'm
constantly scanning my body and
releasing here is what I'm seeing this
is where you deviate from the skill so
I'll be here you see that right I'll
give it even extra you see this watch me
you start to release what do you think
is gonna happen I'm going to fall
forward but watch me tense am i falling
forward no but if you pay attention this
body is wavering you see that
and I'm kind of like fly-by-wire wing
flap it's constantly moving to keep me
in this position
but that's not what I want I want to
release can you see the release I
release a release and instead I'm using
the articulation capacity to keep the
weight falling naturally from the
gravitational pull not a tension that
allows me to do things like this and not
have gravity pulling on me do you
understand okay try it again next one
this time so that top I'm trying to keep
it ain't this time I'm going hunting
move it to skills underneath it and move
it so right now it's on both I'm going
to move over and take it off of one and
I will have to use the articulations
that I mentioned to keep that mid-foot
they're never going to take it back to
the other
and you can't go by my needle can't come
by my toes
you can't go pass and back I go on that
mid-foot weight vector then move it over
release the tension pay attention the
glues in the lower leg and move it over
release every time release play with
your breath chin knee ankle pelvis
release try okay next to my kneels out
turn my toes out turn my kilos out and
now push my knees on that middle vector
running from the front to the back okay
gravity is pulling down I'm going to use
my chin pelvis knee ankle angles to
allow that to happen
I'm consciously relaxing but this time
I'm going to use the arch of my legs to
still keep the weight on the mid-foot if
I do this incorrectly I don't have an
external integrity from on the inside
then you'll see something I'll do it
exaggerate it like this
the weight is pushing my feet out as I
have an a-frame okay I don't want that I
still going to aim it on that mid foot
spot
and I release again release and when I
release don't release the inside because
it's two things the designated spot and
relaxation so right now the weight and
the structure of the arch is enough
architectural integrity to get that
mid-foot and feel it press down press
down press down release release the
glutes release the lower legs and feel
the sting try
I want to feel if if my weight is
dropping straight between my feet
there's a displacing energy it's pushing
outward it can't be pushing inward
if I push inward my center spot can't
drop this stuff's in the way but if I
release that and I let it drop it's
actually pushing outward can you
understand that so when I see your knees
go like that
that's a tension movement release here
feel that spot if I'm feeling it too
much on the outside to see it's starting
to curl my feet up well that's obviously
the downward pressure come back up a
little if you come up too much I'm going
to go backwards that's ruining my
vectoring here relaxing is actually
what's necessary for my knees to pop
open I don't need to keep tension to
allow the structure to happen and I also
don't have to leave structure when I
relax
wherever you're right you can release
the tension you don't have to go like
this
I can keep my arm here and release the
tension I can keep my knees here and
start releasing the glutes to keep the
shape okay go
next drill
hands out keep the spot
keep the spot please
so the our make those micro articulating
angles release the tension
slowly up this is just like the head
rope keep Amy Amy release the tension so
that it drops
baby little tiny micro adjustments to
keep that mid-foot spreading Here I am
if I stop the articulation what's gonna
happen going forward if I hold tension I
can stay here all day
relax no change the pelvis angle I dream
that slowly starting to aim the vector
back and everybody's attention okay okay
establish the vector we're going to
combine the movement right now up and
down wait on my chin like my head I'm
gonna touch my hands
and they're gonna move my hips out of
this position but I'm still decadent
mid-foot back down into mid-foot up
individual down the mid-foot combine the
breath
[Music]
feel the spine create the arc energy add
the wrist into the way the adjustment
thumbs come up pinkies go down
cause we bothering pretension
hey let's go so if I stay here I'm
staying at the bottom and I start to
live in my house watch what's going to
happen what do you think go forward
the articulation has to come up you see
if I take my hands away but you can't
dis loop two hands whenever you
understand if you would stick to that
vectoring pressure it would tell you
when to do it
just like I told you when you moved your
head so I'm here where do I rise when I
feel I'm starting to fall forward start
to rise wait is now back on the mid-foot
you see same thing when I go down right
if I'm up here at the top right do you
understand so when you're at the top you
which is what you see instead is that I
meet my hands about here is where they
are now at a downward orientation
they're not in a downward orientation or
downward orientation and I meet at the
bottom needed to talk have a move
start to move
okay I have to sew it up yeah okay look
here my hands come closer they are
shapes not like that like this there's a
cup right there like a puppy California
Poppy see the ring finger points right
into the middle you see that
forget my feet Shane keeping
not like this not like this
right
okay try the drill again keep those same
palms against the palm shape is not
really relevant to the finger shape to
st. Paul attention get that foot
down at the bottom it's the same exact
drill when do I go up when if I don't
right I just start to fall forward
unless I can't boom with your breath
down have I gone down yet no you tend to
want to pull down with your body you
pull no boom I don't want you to cut I
want you to do the weight manipulation
read bactrim don't worry about putty
try okay
in drill blood what allowed for that x
value to increase releasing right
relaxing this is what I'm seeing now I
just see the vector e so you're here
like that
all right seeing cosmetic the percussion
that you saw I've seen in cosmetic you
see the tension was not this achieved by
a relaxation or releasing now I'm up now
I release up release release
not
see got this rear knee bend and you see
it
watch what'll happen if I release it on
to the original vectors travel this neck
Manama that factor I'm up release
look at my grip notice the end of my
sword is bouncing
you see the bounce of my man
your sword is the same relief
try
what what is holding this what is the
sword once today well the longer end
wants to drop yeah I am taking the
energy of the swords gravity
gravitational pull and vectoring it down
to my feet so if the sword tip wants to
drop you see that what happens to the
other end it lifts but if I have my
weight there you can't drop do you
understand
you guys don't trust that and you take
your fingers and hold it up here okay so
I'm over here and lace comes here and
lace tended to pull the sword right out
so because I'm constantly vectoring like
that in the right way I don't need want
to grip in this drill in any stage you
can come at any stage go ahead whenever
you want you just pull it out ever you
want just grab it pull it do you
understand so when you go like this and
you have that tension usually you have
the tension because you don't have the
vectoring
like you think you do and you having to
control the sword through flight this is
you can don't control the sword blend
with the sword 11 of the storage can you
see that can you see okay so at the
bottom when I'm here I don't need to
grab it and shake it okay I go it's
loose oh it's little pulling down
why is it shaking now it's running into
the hand this yeah it's not because my
wrist bones are going you see that it
wants to spin the Cente used to throw
his sword and spin it I'm not going to
do that okay but that's what the sword
wants to do as it's going like this it
wants to go topsy-turvy
but I'm blending with the top part you
see I'm blending with
and when we all stop and we hit the
vector pulling hit stop and it bounces
off of that it's not me having a tight
grip right it's very loose loose loose
this position I am NOT pushing you as I
move it drags that foot it's dragging it
you see and when I have all this vector
I can pick it up but now it's dragging
the foot I'll show you the difference
when I'm here like that
and I go like this as I pick it up
you're gonna do more movement that way
okay everything is over here it's over
there and as I pick it up I stayed there
you see that I'm not going like this
everything moves over there it's over
there and then it picks up you see that
create tribes and we have this drove
already our feet right here like this
you see that do you remember this drum
there should be no weight on that foot
you see I'm here my line of gravity is
not on the mid-foot which is why when I
take this other foot up you have to
see that you were tasked with putting it
on that mid-foot and now there should be
no tills you see I'm doing that okay now
we just widen it even more take the
first line way over there and now there
should not be tilt because I should have
all my weight on that mid foot this this
line with relaxation is over there and
not in the middle over here and then
that's okay try there's things you can
check okay if I bring this over here you
see my knee there's no way on that mid
foot I'm using tension and that's what
to hold me here if my knee is buck see
this my knee is not in line with my toes
it's Bob you see that here's the toe
line here's back yes or no yes okay then
there's no way you're at mid foot mid
foot weight is going to require your
knee to your the tip of your patella to
be in the tip of your toes do you
understand and in alignment with that
vector that cuts linearly through your
foot no no this will be also wrong okay
try to get ready I'm here now I'm going
to turn and we're gonna just work on
those two abdominal points knee over
shift back
mid-foot line here here feel the same
pressure you were trying to feel heater
that you're trying to fill here that you
were trying to feel it here and you're
trying to fill up here we're just here 1
foot made foot vector letter a dropping
release
release glute lower legs right
it's not this drop
so if I'm over here even though that
foots on the ground how is the only way
I could have weight on it yeah my mid
thigh my centerline is not actually over
this thing you see that because if it's
over this thing there's nothing on that
yeah okay try it again what you have
been doing is releasing and using the
mass of your own body to release from
other angles and aim it at particular
angles okay but the mass of your body is
a force when you moved your head that
course was not comin straight down your
spine you did various things with those
are points of articulation to have it
aim and put more weight on that mid-foot
factor do you understand if you didn't
what happened you would not affect on
the big food you fall forward or you
fall backwards same thing would you
breath
same thing with the arms same thing with
the sword you were a me what was not in
and of itself at that mid-foot better do
you understand yes it didn't matter that
it was up and down because if I didn't
aim it it wouldn't hold me off
so this time as he pushes I'm good he's
just energy and I'm going to aim the
energy into the back foot okay so you
could take I'm in that drill and I went
here now he's going to increase my
gravitational pull I should feel that
more that more sinky okay if I'm tense
up here it will rise up from that mid
foot you might feel it here you might
feel it here you might feel it here or
here how tense you are that's how close
you will feel into his grip how relaxed
you are that is how much goes into the
ground just like your corpse pose the
tent she wore it did not go down to the
ground
do you understand he goes so what you
have to do relax just let this go down
you want him to push you into that this
is relaxed I don't even care much I'm on
stage now just feel that get heavier and
relax
and the more you relax just like corpse
pose you should feel it go down it's
going down more he's feel about an inch
into the mat now okay let's try it
so weight drop is weight store
we're gonna do this okay and I start
neutral and I let it go down and then
release not release and now I'm gonna
drop on this then we go back we vector
release release release forget all this
the more you you try to push this the
less comes from the ground now don't
push it just leave it in space almost
pretend he's not there hey even in
second drill doing course close I had
you tense so you can release but you
were just asked release and then you
were told what release
so what did that mean had to happen in
between attention we want the tension
that's the yawn so everything is inside
now okay here I go
and it's very important that he doesn't
absorb it in his elbow so I get the
feedback so it comes in heels that start
to draw draw attention
okay time okay what did this sword want
to do why did it bounce my weights on
the backside you can't do what it wants
to do and I had enough mass that it had
to be the one that's displaced
what does he want to do oh he's pushy so
I'll take me out of the equation
he wants to go that way in this drill I
sent it down to the ground his intention
gets overridden by that mouse and that's
where he bounces he's not it's not a
displacement this way so he keeps
pushing and you see the drill starts
over here this is not the projection
here release start to drill over
[Music]
so I'm not fooling him see I let him
loathe me I'm going to go all the way
around this time let the energy load I'm
not pulling it still energy turn it drop
it on the front in weight on the front
foot
[Music]
here
so that's one drill one skill Bigfoot
factory the releasing that allows for
mid-foot vectoring that's the primary
we're going to do something else with it
okay so he's there and he is mid-foot
waiting right so he should be happy
got it okay I'm gonna take this it's not
done of these rest you know just like it
wasn't anyways pushing down on me he's
pushing that way
yeah there's energy there there's energy
on the friction between us got it
if I stay light enough I can start to
move this on to my next venture
so he's mid footing and I will feel that
weight you see and I meant footing now
on the front foot and I will be live
enough and I'm moving it in fine and
lifting it's not gonna do it right if
I'm to like it's not gonna do it I have
to be relaxed so I can take that
friction energy and feel it pushing me
down do understand - out of it you see
not push is he pushing me down right
here No
okay well here is energy and rather than
it being only here I'm going to vector
it down into my foot and I can move it
as I shift my weight okay try it okay
he's not resting on he's using its own
arms to mid-foot away
this is right you can see I'm right so
we're gonna go here not friction
sensitive released enough till you feel
it make your feet heavy right you know I
got you already I feel it I gave it to
my foot you see what I got you this one
here generate in here pls
and then you're on the inside okay this
is so many ways
this
I'm on the back
back pull enough to feel the connection
it's waiting me down and now I try
not it's not me going like like this and
then he goes like that
the same exact drill here we are feel
the friction pull the friction that's
all pull the fish
[Music]
that's what I
so I see crowds there I'm already you
keep your hand open keep ohand open I've
already used in it we've seen more to
using it it's not me grab let's not be
manipulating him on there's no word in
the friction the friction ice let go the
friction do you see the connection the
adhesion it's there it's there it's here
but if I go you ask you too much of it
it's inches or fractions right
millimeters fractions of seconds
so here it's there here it's there it's
there it's there I go here my basket at
the mall that happens telling you where
to step so I feel it stop everything
[Music]
but absorb relax we're stuck we're stuck
right now we're stuck coming off so why
do you think I do the next half zip not
one picks up do you think this one picks
up picks up this one ruin your face
[Music]
pass through y'all here not here you see
that difference here on this foot okay
friction whoa here comes the young face
of this one but I'm on this foot his
mask that I'm trying to throw is as a
force as much as when he's pushing at me
do you see so he's just grounding me and
I'm using the ground huh and now this is
just shoving some I won't charge charge
the ground charge the ground the ground
is charged the ground is charged what
we're going
[Music]
we're finding through our technique okay
so yeah I don't have my key no but I
have the principles so it's the friction
right you see and now we're just turn
the friction you see it did I'm going to
turn it this way that way so even though
he's holding me it doesn't matter I was
still doing the same thing I'm still
doing the same thing you see still doing
the same thing that taste right he's
strong right but the stronger you get
then the more he wait he's waking me
he's in and
let's see let's do here have your back
foot rounded back foot rounded on the
weight of your arm garrison okay but you
see how to the way more friction now I'm
saying can you feel that put your weight
on the front foot rounded front you see
how like that it's lighter slightly the
pull put your weight on the back foot
okay and now because you have more young
going that way and I have y'all going
this way
pressure is fire right there you see
okay so I don't need my hands he's going
to be brakes on the back foot and I'm
gonna go okay feel the friction stay
like oh whoa
feel it it'll ground this foot use the
energy to drop that foot once that foots
grounded then pull it go he's grounded
Brown get out here and I aim that
friction energy into the front foot so I
have it and I just keep it keep it
factory and eventually you it's not
anything it's not a hook or anything
okay you just keeping it keeping it
keeping it all right you starting to go
off
one hand he's on the back i feel the
friction it grounds me there and once I
have the connection I start to pull it
and you'll feel it going in
that's about all I get okay then this
hand does it so it's not this it's just
to friction pulls wool wool and then
mid-foot now come in with the cross push
now
okay I still have the same friction well
can you go out then you go and you go
out do you see on your she can't go out
do you see that different so he comes in
and we're connected can't can he go
forward no he can't go forward on yours
can you go forward yes you can but
actually what you're using right you see
that you're using him to come forward
and that's the class I have a connection
boom boom connection move it
I'm moving him move him do you see it's
really a wrestling move it's just that a
distance
we're over here your version once we're
here stuck stop
[Music]